la victoria del país en rama habría sido
aún más histórica si hubiera ganado la
final a donde llegó por primera vez
decepción mucha y asco porque
francamente 10 no es una buena jugada no
es una buena final todos dijimos que el
bayern no había tenido una carrera
increíble entonces tenían que habernos
golpeado de a tres no de a uno poco
donde miles de aficionados se reunieron
frente a una gran pantalla cerca del
estadio para animar al psg pero fueron
testigos de su derrota 1-0 en lisboa
contra el bayern tan pronto como el
partido terminó las tensiones crecieron
y se registraron enfrentamientos en los
campos elíseos donde hubo incendio de
vehículos y destrozo de tiendas más de
150 personas fueron detenidas por
violencia contra las fuerzas del orden
daños a la propiedad y rechazo de las
órdenes de dispersión entre ellas se
encontraban 49 menores de edad o no aquí
con una comunión con el mundo actual
hemos pasado por todas las huelgas las
protestas de los chalecos amarillos todo
y ahora esto realmente no lo
necesitábamos
incluso mientras se lucha contra la
contención del virus francia permite que
hasta cinco mil personas asistan a
grandes eventos siempre y cuando se
mantenga medidas de distanciamiento
social pero estas fueron ignoradas entre
los aficionados que esperaban ver el
primer triunfo de su equipo la policía
afirmó también que más de 400 personas
fueron detenidas por no llevar
mascarillas ahora obligatorias en
algunas partes de la ciudad lo que llevó
a la vicealcaldesa de parís a cargo de
los asuntos de salud a decir que todos
los hinchas que siguieron el partido
deberían hacerse la prueba de
coronavirus